jolie chanson que je n'ai jamais entendue avant la
nouvelle avez-vous faim nous en avons plutôt je
ne veux pas dire votre nourriture que vous ne
volez pas nous offrons allez ça
va être une nuit froide dans laquelle
vous vous dirigez  South King Sunday
pauvre fille c'est une mauvaise affaire, cela dépend
de vos goûts, je suppose que si vous aimez vos
rues couvertes de merde et de sang de porc,
c'est la ville pour vous pour ma vie seulement
pour voir le mouton rouge accepté Baelor la
fosse aux dragons puis quand j'ai enfin  faites en sorte
qu'ils ne laisseraient pas bouger dans un mile le rouge
gardez-le réglé sur les bas de la baie soufflés en enfer
et la fosse aux dragons s'est assise ruiner les gens
qui vivaient là-bas je vous écorcherais vif
s'ils pouvaient faire deux poppers de votre peau le
pire endroit  dans le monde, que
faites-vous dans le Riverland, il y a eu du
mal à formuler les jumeaux,
alors nous nous séparons de l'armée qui a été envoyée pour
maintenir la paix ici, vous allez deviner d'abord je
sais que je ne pouvais pas non plus en avoir assez ma
mère a toujours dit  moi d'être gentil avec les
étrangers étrangers d'être gentil avec vous
très long chemin fr  à la maison, je suis sûr que tu as
eu des aventures oh ouais des aventures sans fin,
ils chanteront sur nous
pendant mille ans la vérité est que quand
nous avons quitté la maison, nous pouvons attendre de partir mais
maintenant nous sommes partis depuis un moment nous  Je ne peux pas
aimer rentrer à la maison Je pense juste à mon
père là-bas sur son bateau tout seul
regarde ici nous faisons ma femme dit que
notre premier bébé va bien qui sait que
vous pensez que les soldats reçoivent des corbeaux avec des nouvelles
de la maison J'espère que c'est une fille  pourquoi
s'occupe-t-il de leur papa quand le chiot
a grandi, quitte toujours le combat
et les loups de quelqu'un d'autre êtes-vous
assez vieux pour boire
c'est du vin de mûre je l'ai fait moi-même 20
bonnes épouses une gentille fille seule en
direction de King's Landing I  Je vais
tuer la reine
[Rires]
toi